.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Heitere Gitarrenmusik *
* Peach Weber
singt eine fröhliche Melodie. *
Ich bin ein sehr ernsthafter Mensch.
Jemanden, der nur noch Witze macht,
nimmt niemand mehr ernst.
Das ist einfach ein Hansjoggel.
Das möchte ich auch nicht sein.
Ich möchte
beide Seiten zeigen können:
meine ernste Seite
und meine lustige Seite.
* Fröhlicher Gesang *
Er ist einer der erfolgreichsten
Komiker und Alleinunterhalter
der Schweiz: Peach Weber.
Das war schon früher immer
mein Traum:
mein eigener Chef zu sein.
Ich kann sehr gut allein
etwas machen.
Zu den Auftritten
fährt Peach fast immer allein.
Auch heute.
Am Abend wird ihn im luzernischen
Ebikon sein Publikum erwarten.
Schon um 14 Uhr
macht er sich auf den Weg.
Diese Woche ist etwas an der Grenze.
Ich lege mir zwei-, dreimal pro Jahr
selber ein Ei.
Dann habe ich z.B. ein Wochenende
mit vier Auftritten.
Bis jetzt ging es immer. Vorher ...
... weiss man einfach, dass
vier Tage lang alles klappen muss.
Und wenn es geklappt hat, denkt man,
man sei ein absoluter Hirsch.
"Mit 70
habe ich das noch mal hingekriegt."
Wenn man so was gemacht hat,
hat man auch ein gutes Gefühl,
wenn man dann
eine Zeit lang nichts macht.
Ich hasse diese Rostkunst.
(Navi) Nach 200 m im Kreisverkehr
geradeaus
auf der Hauptstrasse bleiben.
In fast 50 Jahren
hat der Aargauer eine geballte Ladung
Humor abgeliefert.
Das ist schon etwas armselig.
Jetzt habe ich endlich
eine eigene Fernsehsendung
wie andere Stars auch -
Frank Sinalco, Katharina Polenta ...
Tja ...
Hoi zusammen.
Lasst uns etwas Musik machen!
Mmh, "High Fidelity".
Hol-dri-a-ho, oder?
* Jubel und Applaus *
Oder? Hol-dri-a-ho, oder? Oder?
"Blödeln kann nur,
wer nicht wirklich blöd ist",
sagt Peach Weber
laut dieses Zettels.
Ich glaube, das stimmt.
Jemand, der blöd ist,
kann nur blöd tun,
der kann nicht blödeln.
Dafür braucht es ein bisschen mehr.
Darum ist es ein Kompliment,
wenn jemand sagt: "Der blödelt."
Ich finde das nicht abschätzig.
- Wir hören zu, wie Sie blödeln.
# Sun, fun and nothing to do.
Everybody!
(Alle) # Sun, fun and ...
* Er macht komische Geräusche. *
* Lachen *
Give me some power!
"Nimmst du zum Grillen Kerosin,
fliegt dein Steak ins Engadin."
Nicht so gut, aber selbst gemacht.
Ich bin ja nicht dumm.
Nein. Nein.
* Lachen *
Ich habe sechs Jahre
die Universität abgeschlossen.
Ich war Hauswart.
* Lachen *
Bei einem Grossteil der Gags mache
ich mich über mich selbst lustig.
Das ist aber nicht abendfüllend.
Ich muss auch andere
drannehmen können.
Aber natürlich
ist das nie bösartig gemeint.
Das ist einfach neckisch.
Sonst kann man keinen Humor machen.
Wenn ein Gag im Programm ist,
nehme ich ihn nicht raus,
weil sich jemand betroffen fühlt.
Es gibt kein Thema, bei dem sich
niemand betroffen fühlen kann.
Humor ist etwas,
das immer ein bisschen verletzt.
Sonst kann man nur noch Witze
über zwei, drei Themen machen.
Vielleicht
über eine Karotte oder ein Chips.
Das gibt ja kein Programm.
Gut, Karotten sind auch heikel.
Vegetarier
bin ich eben irgendwie schon,
wenn man es
von der richtigen Seite betrachtet.
Ich bin einfach
indirekter Vegetarier.
Alle meine Lebensmittel
sind Vegetarier.
* Lachen *
Dann müsste es für mich auch ...
* Applaus *
Dann müsste es für mich auch gelten.
Ich möchte mich gar nicht
über Vegetarier lustig machen.
Also, eine kleine Frage
darf man sicher stellen.
Eine kleine Frage:
Wenn wir Tiere nicht essen sollen,
warum sind sie dann aus Fleisch?
* Lachen *
Ist das zu overdressed, um ...
Sein Haus in Hägglingen
nennt er seine kreative Oase.
Es wächst jeweils schon etwas zu,
aber das freut mich.
Dann kann ich
wie in der Wildnis roden gehen.
Geil.
Das ist ein Erholungsraum für mich.
Ich gehe nicht in die Ferien.
Ich habe kein Ferienhaus.
Ich gehe in den Garten.
Das reicht mir.
Da muss ich nicht weit fahren
und im Stau stehen.
Da kann man
eben nicht viel kaputt machen.
Ein Kräutergarten
ist nicht so sinnvoll für mich,
weil ich Kräuter auf dem Essen
gar nicht so mag.
Wenn das Essen gut ist, brauche ich
keine Kräuter und viele Gewürze -
Kardamom und all das Zeugs und so.
Wenn etwas gut ist,
kann man es so lassen.
Ich habe natürlich
mal eine Kochsendung gemacht.
Also, eine Versuchssendung.
Grüezi miteinander.
Ich stehe wieder in meiner Küche
und habe einen Gast eingeladen.
Wir versuchen heute mit Uriella
etwas zu machen.
Hallo, Peach.
Ich habe mich vorbereitet.
- Wirklich?
Ich habe gelesen,
dass du Lichtnahrung machst.
Ich habe schon was vorbereitet,
das wir dann kochen können.
Das sind 60- und 40-Watt-Birnen.
Wir können also sogar
Trennkost machen.
Meine Idee war: Weder ich
noch mein Gast können kochen.
Wir kochen etwas zusammen.
Kann man das öffnen
oder explodiert das?
Nein, die Explosion
ist schon lange vorbei.
Ist es gut, das zu essen?
Sehr gut. Wie Sauerkraut.
Ja, ja. Man nennt das
eigentlich auch Sauerkraut.
Eben.
Aber ich habe etwas Hunger.
Darum habe ich einen Cervelat dabei.
Das graust mir. Nein, bitte.
Nur so zwischendurch.
- Nicht in meiner Gegenwart.
Wenn du wüsstest,
was da alles drin ist.
Lauter Giftstoffe.
- Aha. Aber leckere.
So ein Cervelat hat ja auch
eine erotische Komponente.
Das schüttelt mich direkt.
Geh bitte weg mit dieser Haut!
Das erinnert mich an etwas.
Ich hätte aber in Kauf genommen,
dass man am Schluss sagt:
"Nein, das ist eklig,
wir bestellen eine Pizza."
Wenn Sie wieder mal
nichts essen möchten,
können Sie mir
beim nächsten Mal zuschauen.
Vielleicht
kochen wir dann wirklich etwas.
Wenn man das damals gemacht hätte,
würde man heute sagen,
dass Peach
den ganzen Koch-Boom ausgelöst hat.
Oder?
Es fasziniert mich, dass ich trotz
des Erfolges so bescheiden bin.
* Lachen *
Wer das nicht glaubt -
ich kann es beweisen:
In meinem Testament steht, man solle
kein solches Theater um mich machen,
wie um Elvis Presley.
* Lachen *
Das zeigt meinen Charakter.
Aber etwas liegt schon drin,
ohne dass ich angebe:
Ich könnte die wichtigsten Stationen
meines Lebens aufzählen.
Das Wichtigste aus dem Lebenslauf:
Ich bin 1952
im Alter von neun Monaten geboren.
* Lachen *
Schon dort fragte man sich,
was das gibt.
1958 ging ich in den Kindergarten.
1964 ging ich in die zweite Klasse.
* Lachen *
Ja, zum dritten Mal.
* Heitere Musik *
Peach wächst als Peter Mario Weber
in Wohlen auf -
zusammen mit seiner Schwester Carla
und seinem Bruder Marcel.
Im Trio der Geschwister
ist Peter der Älteste.
Weil es in seiner Schulklasse
mehrere Peter gibt,
nennt er sich Peach.
Tiere spielen in der Familie
eine grosse Rolle.
Der Vater
ist freischaffender Architekt
und hat ein spezielles Hobby:
Er züchtet exotische Vögel,
die er auch öffentlich ausstellt.
Vogelfreund Cesar Weber ist
mit Recht stolz auf die Ausstellung.
Die Ausstellung "Tiere und Blumen"
in Wohlen
zeichnet sich
durch sehr viele Seltenheiten aus.
Wer glaubhaft machen kann, dass er
all die Tiere schon mal gesehen hat,
ist unser Gast.
Jeder tausendste Besucher
wird mit einer Orchidee geehrt.
Und auf den fünftausendsten Besucher
wartet eine besondere Überraschung.
Meine Eltern gaben mir
ein wahnsinniges Urvertrauen mit.
Das war sicher nicht bewusst.
Einfach durch ihre Art als Menschen
konnten sie einem das geben.
Von diesem Urvertrauen
zehre ich heute noch.
Das ist eine Energie, die mir
bis heute ein gutes Gefühl gibt.
* Gefühlvolle Klaviermusik *
Meine Mutter sagte immer:
"Das kommt schon gut."
Wahrscheinlich wusste sie,
dass es nicht gut kommt,
aber sie wollte einem Mut machen.
Das hat auch Nachteile:
Sie hat immer alles
in sich reingefressen.
Sie stellte sich selbst
immer hinten an.
Es kamen immer zuerst alle anderen.
Aber das höre ich heute noch:
"Das kommt schon gut."
"Doch, doch, das kommt schon gut."
* Heitere Musik *
Jetzt geradeaus
oder was haben Sie jetzt vor?
(Navi) Nach 200 m geradeaus
auf der Hauptstrasse bleiben.
Gerade über den Kreisel. Ja.
Auf dem Weg zum Auftritt gönnt er
sich fast immer einen Zwischenstopp.
Oh, das ist eine schöne Beiz.
Ich machte das immer allein.
Es fiel mir auch nicht auf,
dass ich es allein mache.
Ich genoss es z.B. extrem,
um 00.30 Uhr nachts
nach Hause zu fahren.
Es hatte fast keinen Verkehr,
ich hörte etwas Musik ...
Ich empfand das als positiver,
als jemanden neben mir zu haben,
der ununterbrochen
immer etwas redet.
Noch heute ist es mir am wohlsten,
das allein zu machen.
Ich fing nicht an zu singen,
weil ich finde,
ich könne singen
oder Gitarre spielen.
Seit der Erfindung der Gitarre
gab es immer wieder Leute,
die das Instrument
nicht beherrschten.
Diese Tradition
möchte ich weiterführen.
* Sanfte Melodie *
Ich wusste nicht, dass ich
so genial Gitarre spielen kann.
Nein, ich kann wirklich nichts.
Ich war in der Kadettenmusik.
Der Dirigent der Musik
sagte aus Goodwill,
ich solle doch mal
das Horn oder so ausprobieren.
Die Posaune gab er mir nicht,
weil er wusste,
dass das noch schwieriger ist.
Am Schluss
hatte ich nur noch die Tschinellen.
Aber nur schon das
war eine Herausforderung.
Da merkte ich, dass ich wohl nicht
mit Musik mein Geld verdienen werde.
Und doch schaffen es
seine musikalischen Spässe
immer wieder
in die Schweizer Single-Hitparade.
* Lachen *
* Heitere Melodie *
Wahnsinn, oder?
# I bi de Borkechäfer,
de Borkechäfer - schmatz, schmatz.
# Schmatz, schmatz, schmatz,
schmatz, schmatz.
# Sun, fun and nothing to do.
Come on!
# Come on, baby, I love you.
Everybody!
# Sun, fun and nothing to do.
# Only you my Schatz
and the Luftmatratz.
Very good. Very good.
Now I make a solo on my Büchsen.
* Lachen *
I learnt this
at the Konservatorium.
* Lachen *
Yeah.
* Lachen und Applaus *
Musikalisch versucht sich Peach
zuerst als Schlagzeuger.
Ich war der Einzige
aus meinem Freundeskreis,
der ein Schlagzeug hatte.
Aber nicht, weil ich gut war.
Ich hatte einfach
ein eigenes Schlagzeug,
das ich jeden Monat
mit 20 Fr. abzahlen musste.
Ich sah aber sehr bald ...
... dass ich nie so gut werde,
wie ich werden möchte.
Es fehlte einfach
ein gewisses Grundtalent.
Aber ich hatte Freude daran.
Das spielte damals
nicht so eine Rolle.
Es musste laut sein, auch
wenn es manchmal grauenhaft klang.
Wir haben eigentlich
den Punk erfunden.
Unser Ziel war, möglichst schnell
den Saal zu leeren.
Man kann das
nicht unbedingt Musik nennen.
Das war irgendein ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Das war Rock-Abfall.
* Rockige Klänge *
Ich spielte sogar in zwei Bands.
Eine hiess - das darf man
fast nicht laut sagen - Urino Brünz.
Das war damals als Lehrer
natürlich etwas heikel.
Ich hängte dann auch Flyer auf.
Das hätte schon schiefgehen können.
Ich hatte auch als Lehrer
noch lange Haare -
bis fast an den Po runter.
Und ich trug einen Lammfellmantel.
Damit war man schon fast ein Rebell.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Nach dem Seminar
unterrichtet Peach acht Jahre lang
als Oberstufenlehrer in Wohlen.
Wenn ich heute 20 wäre,
würde ich
garantiert wieder unterrichten.
Man musste mit Motivation arbeiten,
nicht mit Druck.
Das faszinierte mich am Lehrerberuf.
Ich finde das
einen der schönsten Berufe,
mit Kindern arbeiten zu können.
# I bin es Aargauer Büebli.
# Und han es ganz grosses Problem.
* Lachen *
# Di andere Schwiizer
lached mi mängisch us,
# aber i glaube,
die chömed nid drus.
# I bin en Aargauer
und bi stolz dadruf.
# I bin en Aargauer, also passid uf.
# Das weiss doch scho
afang jedes Chind,
# dass mir Aargauer
eifach e chli besser sind.
# I bin en Aargauer
und bi stolz dadruf.
Wohlen ist für mich
schon wie eine Heimat.
Aber es hat sich auch dort ...
Sonst wäre ich ja nicht weg.
Es gab dort auch Veränderungen,
die mir nicht mehr passten.
Auto-Partei, SVP-Hochburg und so.
# Autobahne hämmer chrüz und quer.
# Das bruche mir au,
denn es git vil Verchehr.
# Millione vo Tourischte
wännd in Aargau cho
# und vor luuter Begeischterig
bliibeds am Baregg stah.
# I bin en Aargauer
und bi stolz dadruf.
In seinen jungen Jahren
fasst Peach den Entschluss,
sich politisch zu engagieren.
Auslöser sind ungelöste Verkehrs-
und andere Probleme in Wohlen
und dass sich in der
örtlichen Politik kaum etwas bewegt.
Immer nur rummotzen geht auch nicht.
Man sollte auch mal Verantwortung
übernehmen und mitmachen.
Dann hat man es wenigstens versucht.
Ich fragte dann noch einen Freund,
ob er mitkomme.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Mit JoeWanni Ludin,
den er aus der Schulzeit kennt,
gründet er eine Partei,
die in der Lokalpolitik
mitreden will.
Wir sind hier in Wohlen.
Das Gebäude hinter mir ist der Ort,
an dem Peach Weber und ich
quasi eine Partei gründeten.
Es lief etwas anders:
Peach
wurde als Einzelperson gewählt.
Dann gab es
so viele Stimmen für uns,
dass wir
eine Partei gründen konnten.
Aus "Euse Maa" wird "Eusi Lüüt".
Die Partei wächst
und hält den konservativen
Wohler Einwohnerrat auf Trab.
Politisch mitmachen
entstand daraus ...
... dass in Wohlen viele schöne,
alte Häuser abgerissen wurden.
Meistens kam dann eine Bank dorthin.
Oder irgendein hässlicher Zweckbau.
Wir fanden,
das sei keine gute Entwicklung.
Da gehe etwas kaputt.
Dann fingen wir halt an,
uns dagegen einzusetzen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wir wollten die Anliegen umsetzen,
die von den Politikern
nicht aufgegriffen wurden.
Also, Verkehrsberuhigung,
Abbruch von Häusern verhindern,
sogar Anti-KKW,
also Anti-Kernkraftwerk.
Wir vertraten solche Bewegungen.
Atomkraft ist ein Thema,
das Peach nie losgelassen hat.
Ich fand den Weg mit den AKWs
immer falsch.
Das ist ein Holzweg.
Als Junge kriegte ich ein Buch:
"Das Atom, dein Freund".
Damals hatte man Freude daran.
Man dachte:
"Jetzt haben wir Atomkraft und
können unendlich Energie machen."
30 Jahre lang
wurde man als Spinner abgestempelt,
wenn man sagte,
dass etwas passieren könnte
oder dass der Abfall
so lange aufbewahrt werden muss.
Als links-grün versiffter ...
... ja, Träumer.
Ich bin Teil der Generation,
die das verursacht hat.
Das war billiger Strom
und wir dachten,
dass damit
alle Probleme gelöst sind.
Es hat noch niemand
eine Lösung gefunden,
wie man auch nur 1 kg dieses Abfalls
für 100'000 Jahre lagern kann.
Nur schon dabei
sollten doch alle sagen:
"Das ist idiotisch."
* Lockere Musik *
Bereits in den 70er-Jahren
haben sich Peach und seine Kollegen
aktiv mit der Problematik
der Atomkraftwerke auseinandergesetzt
und einen Kurzfilm gedreht.
Die Demonstrationen
im nahe gelegenen AKW Gösgen
und auf dem Gelände
des geplanten AKW Kaiseraugst
haben damals
die ganze Schweiz bewegt.
Ich mache sie darauf aufmerksam,
dass der Zutritt zum Kraftwerk
polizeilich gesperrt ist.
* Knallgeräusche *
Ich habe nie
gegen AKWs demonstriert.
Das ist etwas von dem wenigen,
das ich heute bereue.
Ich bin den Leuten sehr dankbar,
die sich dort hingestellt haben
und sich mit Tränengas und Wasser
bespritzen liessen.
* Knallgeräusche *
Es würde mich stolz machen,
wenn ich sagen könnte,
dass ich dabei war.
Aber weil ich
ein ehrlicher Junge bin,
muss ich sagen,
dass ich das verpasst habe.
* Knall *
Ich habe wieder ein Lied -
und zwar ...
... ein bisschen
ein zusammengesetztes.
Ich mache das gerne:
Lieder, die man kennt,
mit neuem Text zusammensetzen.
Das da ...
Ich habe in der Mitte sogar
noch eine französische Strophe.
Wenn man irgendwo auftritt,
hat es meistens ein, zwei Welsche.
Il y a des autres?
* Lachen *
Keine? Ja, ist egal.
Es tut uns Deutschschweizern gut,
unser mickriges Französisch
aufzupolieren.
Darum eben die französische Strophe.
Das Lied beginnt aber ganz normal:
auf Deutsch.
* Lachen *
# Wennd ä Frau suechsch ...
# Ja, wennd ä Frau suechsch.
# ... v.a.
wennd dini Frau suechsch ...
# Wennd dini Frau suechsch,
de lüütsch mer eifach a.
Französisch. Französisch.
# Je suis je et tu es toi.
# Tu es tu, ta-tü-ta-tü.
# Quelque chose pour les Fransose.
# Comment tu mö, schö-tölö-tö.
# Comment tu mö, schö-tölö-tö-tö.
# Un peu de si, un peu de ça.
# Voulez-vous coucher avec moi?
* Lachen *
# No, no, no,
je ne voulez-vous coucher avec toi.
* Lachen *
* Heitere Musik *
* Applaus *
Jeannette Eggenschwiler
und Peter alias Peach Weber.
Wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt?
Hier steht etwas
von einem Sportplausch. Stimmt das?
Ja.
Ich arbeitete vorher
in einem Verlagshaus.
Ich wurde von der Zeitung
hingeschickt
und Peach als sportliche Prominenz.
- Danke.
Und dort unten, im südlichen
Spanien, lernten wir uns kennen.
Allerdings waren wir
ein paar Monate vorher, im Winter,
schon an einem Plausch, aber da
hatte ich keine Augen für ihn.
Es war wohl zu kalt.
- So ist es.
Ja.
* Applaus *
Die beiden heiraten und bald
kommt Tochter Nina auf die Welt.
Einer der schönsten Momente
in meinem Leben
war ganz sicher
die Geburt meiner Tochter.
Das war wirklich etwas vom Grössten,
das man erleben kann.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das war für mich
eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Ich wusste immer:
Wenn ich ihr etwas mitgeben will,
dann dieses Urvertrauen,
denn damit kommt sie durchs Leben.
Als sie auf die Welt kam ...
Ich war ja ein alter Vater.
Ich war schon um die 40.
Ich sagte mir von Anfang an,
dass ich die Vorteile,
die ich als alter Vater habe,
nutzen muss.
Sonst wäre ich ein Idiot gewesen.
Wenn ich als Zwanzigjähriger
eine Tochter gehabt hätte,
hätte ich sicher
noch viel anderes im Kopf gehabt.
Das passiert ja vielen Vätern.
Ich sagte dort einfach, dass ich
ab sofort an den Wochenenden
praktisch keine Auftritte mehr
mache.
Das war die beste Entscheidung,
die ich je getroffen habe.
Das kann man mit allem Geld usw.
nicht mehr aufwiegen.
Wenn man die Zeit verpasst,
in der ein Kind aufwächst,
kann man nicht nachher mit 16 sagen,
man habe jetzt Zeit,
um von vorne anzufangen.
So.
Nina hat ein abgeschlossenes Studium
in Linguistik.
Der Kontakt mit ihrem Vater
ist eng geblieben,
obwohl sich die Eltern
getrennt haben,
als Nina dreijährig war.
"Übersetzerin und Texterin" -
das klingt cool.
Ich sagte immer, dass ich vielleicht
ein unbrauchbarer Ehemann bin,
aber ein genialer Ex-Mann.
Das würde mir der Berufsberater
wahrscheinlich sagen.
Sie haben das sehr gut gemanagt.
Sie hatten
einen guten Umgang miteinander.
Ich nahm das nicht
als etwas Spezielles wahr.
Für mich war das immer normal
und eigentlich etwas Positives:
Man feierte zweimal Weihnachten.
Oft auch miteinander.
Es gab ein bisschen
einen Patchwork-Family-Groove.
Ich fand das immer schön.
Sie war am Wochenende
eigentlich immer hier.
Jeannette
arbeitete ja am Wochenende.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Mami und Papi
haben einen ähnlichen Humor -
und ich darum eben auch.
Das verband uns immer stark.
Erst, als sie älter wurde ...
... sagte sie -
und darüber freute ich mich -,
sie sei froh, dass sie das
lustig finde, was ich mache.
Das wäre sonst ein Problem.
Das meinte sie sicher ehrlich.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass sie
endlos meine CDs gehört hätte.
Sie hörte andere Dinge
und darüber war ich sehr froh.
Es gibt ja Kinder,
die meine CDs hören,
also v.a. die Lieder.
Das sind arme Eltern,
die das hundertmal hören müssen.
Diesen subtilen, teils trockenen,
aus der Situation entstehenden Humor
mag ich sehr.
Er dreht die Dinge jeweils um
und plötzlich geht der Satz in
eine andere, unerwartete Richtung.
"Ich mittagesse nie,
weil ich stücke sehr spät früh."
Ich bin ja eigentlich
ein richtiger Frauentyp.
Wenn Frauen mich sehen,
sind sie hin und weg.
Also, v.a. weg.
* Lachen *
Aber eine Beziehung
ist etwas Wunderschönes.
Es ist doch einfach schön, wenn man
zu einer Frau nach Hause kommt,
die einen liebt und verehrt,
verständnisvoll,
schlau und leidenschaftlich ist.
Und dann merkt man, dass man
in der falschen Wohnung ist.
Nein, nein.
Nein, Beziehungen sind wichtig.
Wir brauchen mehr Beziehungen
und mehr Kinder.
Kinder sind ja so süss.
Wenn der Kleine mit Hundescheisse
in der Hand aus der Schule kommt:
"Schau mal,
in was ich fast reingetreten bin."
Peach ist auch Autor
von Kinderbüchern.
An die Kindertage in Chur
ist er eingeladen,
um aus seinem Buch "Zwerg Stolperli"
vorzulesen.
Bei Auftritten wie diesem
wird er von einem
langjährigen Kollegen unterstützt.
Ganz genau heisse ich Werner.
Aber es gibt viele Leute,
die mich Walti nennen.
Vielleicht sehe ich aus wie einer.
Es ist warm. Und es hat viele Leute.
Der Sound scheint gut zu sein.
Aber da ist man froh ums Mikrofon.
Sonst würde er "Zwerg Stolperli"
einfach vorlesen.
Aber mit den Kindern
würde man nichts hören.
Mein Job
beinhaltet alles von A bis Z:
Ich fahre zu Peach ...
... fahre mit ihm
an den Aufführungsort ...
... und stelle dort die Anlage auf.
Nach der Vorstellung
gibt er Autogramme und verkauft CDs.
Und ich breche ab und wir reisen ab.
Ganz einfach.
Zwei Personen, ein Team.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Hier in Chur
läuft der Auftritt so ab:
Er liest und hat dazu Bilder
auf einer Staffelei.
Ich muss laufend
die Bilder wechseln.
Ich nehme immer wieder eins weg.
Und die Kinder verstehen das schon.
Wenn ich vergesse zu wechseln,
ruft sicher eines,
weil es das Buch gesehen hat.
Die Bilder gehören dazu.
Für die "Zwerg Stolperli"-Auftritte
braucht Peach so viel Energie
wie für zwei Comedyauftritte.
Die Kinder sind so brutal.
(Frau) In 10 Min., um 13.30 Uhr,
geht es los mit Peach Weber.
Und "Zwerg Stolperli".
Peach Weber heisst Comedy.
Das hätte sie sagen sollen.
Darf ich ein Foto machen?
- Wenn es schnell geht.
Er ist Peach-Weber-Fan.
Es muss schnell gehen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
(Walter)
An den Events passiert das oft.
(Mann) Geh du nach vorne. Hier.
Das ist schon wichtig.
# Zwerg Stolperli, Zwerg Stolperli.
Das singen wir vor.
Dazu stampfen wir -
und die Kinder auch.
Alle müssen mitmachen.
Dafür muss man in Topform sein.
Liebe Kinder ... Hallo!
(Alle) Hallo!
Das ist nichts. Hallo!
- (Lauter) Hallo!
"Tief im Wald,
hinter den drei Bergchen,
wohnten drei Zwergchen."
"Es waren drei Brüderchen."
"Sie wussten nicht,
wie sie dorthin gekommen waren,
aber es war ihnen wohl."
Ihr seht sie auf dem ersten Bild.
"Und wenn Stolperli
jeweils durch den Wald ging,
sang er immer sein Liedchen."
# Zwerg Stolperli, Zwerg Stolperli,
dä stolperet i de Wält umenand.
erläbt so allerhand.
# Und gheit er einisch wieder um,
machts räbedibäbedi-bäbedibumm.
# Aber er staht wider uf,
er hät e lange Schnuf.
Juhui!
Jawohl, super gemacht.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Schon gut. Danke.
Es ...
Merci vielmals.
Ich habe mir in letzter Zeit
öfter gedacht,
dass ich für mein Alter
etwas zu jung bin.
Ich bin jetzt über 60.
Von älteren Leuten hört man immer,
wie schnell die Zeit vorbeigehe.
Das stimmt schon.
Peng und man ist 50.
Dann peng, 60.
Und wenn es dann nicht peng macht,
wird man 80.
Peng, schon ist man peng-sioniert.
* Lachen *
Aber es gibt ältere Leute,
die damit völlig locker umgehen.
Bei der letzten Abstimmung
war ich im Abstimmungslokal
und da war eine alte Frau,
so um die 90.
Plötzlich
sprang sie kopfüber in die Urne.
Ich fragte, was das solle.
Und sie meinte, sie wollte nur
eine Probefahrt machen.
Die hat sich einen abgelacht.
Die lag am Boden vor Lachen.
Da dachte ich: "Verdammt,
so muss man das doch sehen."
Aber die Realität
sieht natürlich anders aus.
Ich frage mich bei jedem Bekannten,
den ich treffe,
ob der wohl
an meine Beerdigung kommt.
Das ist mein Motto:
Ich gehe nur an Beerdigungen von
Leuten, die auch an meine kommen.
* Lachen *
* Lockere Klänge *
Ich bin sehr gerne auf dem Friedhof.
Ich gehe fast jede Woche einmal,
wenn ich in Wohlen bin.
Ich finde das
eine sehr friedliche Atmosphäre.
Es ist sehr philosophisch.
Man weiss einfach, dass man
irgendwann auch hier landen wird.
Das relativiert alles ein bisschen -
v.a., wenn ich sehe,
wie gewisse Leute aus dem Dorf,
die sich ein Leben lang
gezankt haben,
ein paar Gräber auseinander
friedlich nebeneinander liegen.
Ja, für mich
ist das immer eine gute Art,
um über das Leben nachzudenken.
Einer meiner ersten Berufswünsche,
gleich nach dem Milchmann,
war Pfarrer.
Aber meine Beziehung zur Kirche
veränderte sich schon als Junge
massiv -
durch ein Erlebnis,
als ich beichten ging.
Da kam ein Pfarrhelfer in die Kirche
und erschoss sich vor dem Altar.
Ich glaube,
ich war damals elf, zwölf Jahre alt.
Ich verstand einfach nicht,
worum es ging.
Erst später erfuhr ich,
dass er das nur gemacht hatte,
um sich an seinem
ehemaligen Vorgesetzten zu rächen.
Ich dachte schon damals:
"Wenn ihr so miteinander umgeht,
dass es so weit kommt,
dass sich jemand umbringt ...
... müsst ihr mir nicht sagen, was
ich im Leben besser machen soll."
Die Kirche hat für mich
nicht so viel mit Religion zu tun.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es da einen alten Mann hat,
der die Fäden in der Hand hält.
Ich glaube wirklich,
dass es Gutes und Schlechtes
in den Menschen hat.
Je nachdem, was sie erleben,
kommt das eine mehr zum Vorschein.
Darum vertraue ich darauf,
dass durch Menschen,
die anderen helfen,
viel mehr Gutes entsteht,
als durch jemanden, der
jeden Sonntag in die Kirche geht,
aber sonst
ein fragwürdiger Charakter ist.
Ich bin schon ziemlich lange
Mitglied von EXIT.
Ich finde, das ist wie Notwehr
gegen unsere moderne Medizin.
Die geht immer weiter und kann einen
immer länger am Leben erhalten -
auch wenn es
nicht mehr so lebenswert ist.
Das ist von aussen
natürlich schwierig zu entscheiden.
Aber ich sage mir,
dass jeder Mensch weiss,
wenn sein Leben
nicht mehr lebenswert ist.
Da muss niemand reinreden.
Es gibt ja nur die Alternative,
sich vor den Zug zu werfen
oder sich die Kugel zu geben.
Das ist sicher nicht besser.
Darum bin ich sehr froh,
dass wir diese Möglichkeit
seit vielen Jahren haben:
auf eine würdige Art zu gehen,
wenn man keinen Ausweg mehr sieht.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
* Lockere Musik *
Ankunft in Ebikon.
Mit über 300 Zuschauern
ist die Vorstellung ausverkauft.
Der Abend mitten im Hochsommer
verspricht buchstäblich
heiss zu werden.
Auch ohne Publikum
ist es im Saal schon über 30 °C warm.
Für einen 70-Jährigen
eine körperliche Herausforderung.
Zum Glück muss sich Peach nicht
auch noch um die Technik kümmern.
Er kann sich in Ruhe
dem Aufbau seines Bühnenbilds widmen.
Ich brauche nicht rund um mich
Helfer mit einem T-Shirt,
auf dem
"Staff - Peach Weber Tour" steht.
Und unter uns gesagt:
Wenn man die Gage abrechnet,
ist man froh, allein zu sein.
Soll ich dir was nehmen?
Wenn du das halten kannst.
Ich bin Selbstständigerwerbender.
Da muss man alles selber machen.
Meine Sache ist so einfach,
da wäre jeder Helfer unterfordert.
Ich könnte auch die Anlage
selber aufstellen.
* Lockere Musik *
Du kannst aus
ästhetischer Perspektive schauen ...
... ob das der Goldene Schnitt ist.
* Lockere Musik *
* Er imitiert einen Elektroschock. *
Wenn das so nahe ist,
wird es grausam warm.
Da verrecke ich.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Kannst du den Monitor
etwas leiser machen?
Lieber zu laut als zu leise.
Es darf nicht zu leise sein.
Das ist der Tod jedes Komikers.
# Eis, zwöi, drü, vier, föif.
# Eis, zwei, drü, vier, föif -
und sächs, sibe, acht, nüün, zäh.
Ich muss dem Techniker immer sagen,
er solle es
etwas zu laut einstellen.
Ja nicht zu leise.
# Und Adieu mitenand.
Eben, die Devise ist:
kurz vor der Schmerzgrenze.
Sobald die Anlage
etwas zu leise ist,
merke ich an der Reaktion der Leute,
dass sie sich
nicht mehr trauen zu lachen,
weil sie denken, dass sie dann
den nächsten Witz verpassen.
Da merkt man sofort,
dass die Stimmung zusammenfällt.
Sobald die Leute
nicht mehr zuhören müssen,
sondern es hören,
können sie voll herauslachen.
Das sind diese kleinen Dinge, von
denen man erst mit der Zeit merkt,
dass die auch noch wichtig sind.
Gitarre zu laut ...
Die Gitarre muss so sein,
dass man den Text gut versteht.
Ich habe diese philosophischen Texte
nicht umsonst geschrieben.
Auf der Bühne ist alles bereit.
Nach und nach
tröpfeln die Zuschauer rein.
Ich gehe hier
über den Fussgängerstreifen.
Oh, da ist rot.
Peach nutzt die Ruhe vor dem Sturm,
um sich noch etwas Verpflegung
zu besorgen.
Grüezi. Welches
ist das frischste Birchermüesli?
Die sind alle gleich.
- Alle gleichzeitig gemacht?
Mein Programm besteht ja
aus verschiedenartigen Gags.
Ich kann nicht 2 Std. einen Hammer
nach dem anderen machen.
Das geht nicht.
Man kann nicht
2 Std. voll durchlachen.
Es braucht einen Rhythmus:
mal welche zum Schmunzeln,
dann einen Hammer
und wieder etwas zum Schmunzeln.
Einfach so viel wie möglich.
Merci.
Dann halten die Leute
auch 2 Std. durch.
Es ist wirklich Hochrisiko.
In der Comedy weiss man jedes Mal,
auch wenn man das
40, 45 Jahre lang gemacht hat ...
Man weiss jeden Abend ...
... dass es theoretisch
in die Hose gehen könnte.
Sie wollte noch
einen Kleber draufmachen.
In der Comedy kannst du so abstürzen
wie nirgends sonst.
Ah, da.
Ja, ja.
Darum ist man auch
hoch konzentriert.
Wenn man aber verunsichert ist,
geht alles in die Hose.
Du kannst dich dann nicht
entschuldigen und noch mal anfangen.
Gut, das könnte noch lustig sein.
Aber wie gesagt:
Comedy ist das höchste Risiko,
das man ...
... in der Unterhaltung
eingehen kann.
* Lockere Musik *
Man kann auch nicht aufstehen,
wenn es nicht gut läuft
und sagen, das Publikum von gestern
habe extrem gelacht.
Das interessiert die von heute
nicht.
Es zählt, was heute Abend passiert.
Was morgen ist oder gestern war ...
... interessiert die von heute
nicht.
Herzlich willkommen: Peach Weber.
* Jubel und Applaus *
# Wenn ein Pferd vorüberschifft ...
äh ... ein Schiff vorüberfährt.
# Und die Ziege zögern ...
äh ... Vögel ziehen davon.
# Alli Fraue ...
# ... wännd nume es Chind vo mir.
* Lachen *
# Aber i ha doch kes vörigs.
# Han welle ufem Riiterhof
ufs Ross ufesitze.
# Chum bini dobe,
da rüeft scho dr Bsitzer:
# "Gib mir mein Pferd zurück,
bevor's auseinanderbricht."
# I bi so fröhli, i bi so fröhli.
# Und das gaht au ohni Alkohöli.
# I bi so fröhli ...
* Lachen *
Über 8'000 Vorstellungen hat Peach
in seinem Leben als Komiker gemacht.
Manchmal mit Helfern,
aber meistens ganz allein.
2027 ist Schluss.
Den allerletzten Auftritt
plant er an seinem 75. Geburtstag
im Zürcher Hallenstadion.
Es war mir immer klar,
dass ich so lange wie möglich
etwas machen möchte.
Es kommt ja darauf an,
wie fit ich bin.
Wenn ich bis 2027 halbwegs fit bin,
mache ich vielleicht ein
eigenes Programm fürs Hallenstadion.
Es kann sein,
dass ich ein Best-of mache.
dass ich so schlecht dran bin,
dass man mich
an die Bühne nageln muss,
damit ich nicht umfalle,
und so dabei sein kann.
Es kann sein,
dass ich gar nicht mehr da bin.
Dann gibt es
eine lustige Gedenkveranstaltung.
Die muss lustig sein.
20 Fr.
Ich lasse das auf mich zukommen.
Bis jetzt bin gut damit gefahren,
zu sagen,
dass es auf irgendeine Art
wahrscheinlich gut kommt.
Mich darauf verlassen.
Dieses Urvertrauen meiner Eltern.
Das ist das Grösste, das man
seinen Kindern mitgeben kann:
ein Urvertrauen,
das ein Leben lang halten kann,
wenn einem das mitgegeben wird.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Man kann Peach nicht vorwerfen,
er habe Starallüren.
Er ist einer wie du und ich.
Er ist kein Chef.
Er ist ein Kollege all derer,
die mit ihm zu tun haben.
Man hat immer
ein kollegiales Verhältnis.
Von Star ist er weit entfernt -
trotz seines grossen Namens.
Jedes Kind in der Schweiz
kennt Peach Weber.
Das ist ganz klar.
Man hat mich mal gefragt,
ob Peach ein einsamer Wolf sei.
Das muss ich bejahen.
Auf eine Art schon.
Aber er schaffte es immer,
nicht einsam zu sein.
Er ist vom Typ her ...
Er kapselt sich nicht ab,
sondern weiss genau,
wo er Leute findet,
die auch gut für ihn sind.
Ja.
Obwohl er allein lebt,
empfinde ich ihn nicht
als einsamen Menschen.
Er ist immer geschäftig und immer
gerne mit Leuten unterwegs.
Und dann aber auch wieder für sich.
Ich merke, dass es ihm wohl ist.
Ich bin sehr happy, dass er es sich
so einrichtet, wie er das möchte.
* Peach hechelt. *
Jetzt geht noch die Tür zu.
* Sanfte Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022